♪♪
Welcome to
"Your Fantastic Mind."
I'm Jaye Watson.
This is the show exploring
the mysteries and the science
of the amazing
human brain.
What does it mean to be
the best at something?
To simply be better at it
than everyone else?
For one man from
South Georgia,
being the best
led him to the NFL.
The path to success
was punishing.
And in the process,
Nate Lewis will tell you,
he lost who he was.
Now he is on a journey to try
to help his brain function
like it used to.
♪♪
In his suburban
Atlanta neighborhood,
Nate Lewis tackles
the asphalt hills.
Each painful step a reminder
of the price of love.
For Lewis,
that love affair began
when he was just
10 years old,
growing up in the South
Georgia town of Moultrie.
(Nate)
It's all about
football down there.
(Jaye)
It was the
football field.
A green oasis in a town
baked and browned
by relentless summers.
(Nate)
I was just, like,
obsessed with the-the
smell of the grass.
And so I would just
get up in the morning
and put my cleats on, and
just go run on the grass.
If it was fresh-cut,
oh, that was emotional.
(Jaye)
It was on the grass
that Lewis,
and everyone who
watched him play,
realized he had a gift.
(Nate)
And I was outrunning them.
I would jump
higher than them.
(Jaye)
A running back
turned wide receiver,
his senior year at
Colquitt County High School,
Lewis was recruited to
the University of Georgia.
Nathaniel Lewis of
Moultrie, Georgia,
high in the air.
(Jaye)
With the ball tucked
under his arm,
his beloved green field
spread before him,
Lewis was unstoppable.
(Nate)
You hear your heartbeat.
You hear yourself breathing,
Then you don't
hear nothin'.
No, you just focus on
where you have to go.
Yeah, that's what
I love to do.
(Jaye)
By the time Lewis
was scoring
against Georgia Tech
and Clemson,
he says he had already
suffered concussions.
Although they didn't
call them concussions.
It was "getting
your bell rung."
(Nate)
About 14-- 13, 14 years old.
You actually
do see stars.
You can't see.
You can't focus.
(Jaye)
Lewis remembers what
the coaches would say.
(Nate)
Like, he said,
"You all right?
"You all right?"
I was like, "No."
He was like,
"Well, come on,
"just take a--
take one play off."
I took a play off.
I wasn't right.
(Jaye)
And then,
the NFL came calling.
In the NFL,
everyone is fast.
Everybody's fast.
Everything's
happening quicker.
(Jaye)
A childhood passion
had led him to the top.
In his six years playing
for the San Diego Chargers
and the Chicago Bears,
the hits kept coming.
How did they treat you for
a concussion when you got one?
Ice.
On top of my head
or on my neck.
(Jaye)
In the NFL?
Oh, yeah.
And besides ice?
That's it.
That was it.
That's the only t--
treatment I got.
(Jaye)
A pastime was
now serious business.
Lewis says he
played through pain
and confusion so severe,
there are entire days of
his career that are a blank.
His wife, Sherry,
reminds him of one time.
The one that you got
on the plane, and--
That was Denver.
And he said that he doesn't
remember the trip home.
He, um, you know,
didn't know where he was.
(Jaye)
Seven years after
he left football,
Sherry says,
Nate changed.
He would get enraged
over nothing.
A drawer left open,
a shoe on the floor.
Very argumentative.
Lack of communication.
He built a wall.
(Jaye)
What else did you see?
(Sherry)
Confusion.
A look in his eye that
just didn't feel the same.
We had a good connection.
And it just
seemed like...
he wasn't there anymore.
And he didn't love me.
(Jaye)
It didn't take much
to set him off.
Did you feel
a lot of rage?
(Nate)
Yes.
(Jaye)
What were you mad about?
(Nate)
Not being able to do--
not being able to
hold a thought.
Not being able to
And because, um,
it's like, you know,
I don't want my wife
to think I'm dumb.
You know, I've been
to college.
I-I was able to do
these type of things.
But I can't
do it no more.
(Jaye)
Sherry would learn
Nate was suicidal,
and thought often of crashing
the 18-wheeler trucks
he now drove to
make a living.
If I was to just drive off
this-drive off this cliff,
everything exploded,
I'd be-- that'd be it.
(Jaye)
They were on
the brink of divorce.
Then came the
turning point.
Junior Seau was one of
the best-known players
in the NFL during...
An apparent suicide
by a powerful athlete,
a force of nature on
the football field.
(Jaye)
Junior Seau, Nate Lewis'
Chargers teammate and friend,
killed himself.
It was heartbreaking,
because the story that
they told behind that
and the struggle that
he was goin' through.
And I'm like, "Wow, I'm goin'
through the same stuff."
(Jaye)
The autopsy would show
Seau's brain had CTE,
Chronic Traumatic
Encephalopathy.
A progressive degenerative
disease of the brain
found in people with a history
of repetitive brain trauma,
such as concussions.
How many concussions
have you had?
I can't count.
I can't really count.
I mean, 'cause--
Five?
More.
Ten?
Twenty?
Yeah, about--
I'd say about that.
Probably more.
Twenty or more.
(Jaye)
Nate and Sherry say Junior
saved their marriage,
and Nate's life.
He got help.
He now takes medicine to
deal with the headaches,
depression, anger,
and attention issues.
All right,
how you doing today?
Good.
How about yourself?
I am good.
Glad to see you.
Same here.
(Jaye)
At Emory Brain
Health Center,
he is doing ecologically-related
neurorehabilitation,
to try to help his brain
function better.
"Write the names down.
Distinguish the physical
facts of the person."
Okay, good.
(Jaye)
W-O-P-R.
Write, Organize,
Picture, Rehearse.
This is Nate's life.
He takes a notebook
everywhere.
Writes what he
needs to remember,
organizes it,
paints a mental picture,
and rehearses recalling
the information.
Today, Nate is working on
remembering names and faces.
Do you remember
this guy's name, here?
(groans)
Hmm?
We talked about
the moustache.
Larry, um...
I remember he played
tennis, right?
He played tennis.
Larry Carlton.
That's right.
Boo-yah.
Good job.
Excellent work.
Yeah, yeah.
(Jaye)
It's not the thrill
of a touchdown,
but it is a victory.
And those happen rarely
for Lewis, these days.
(Dr. Tony Stringer)
Well, certainly,
our nervous system has
tremendous capacity
to heal itself.
What we do in
rehabilitation
is we try to facilitate
that spontaneous recovery.
And-- but even
more importantly,
particularly when we're talking
about cognitive abilities,
what we're really trying
to do is to teach people
to make really good use of their
preserved cognitive skills.
(Jaye)
This rehab isn't new.
Emory Neuropsychologist,
Dr. Tony Stringer,
used it with patients who
suffered brain injuries
in car accidents
20 years ago.
He developed WOPR
and other strategies
that help patients like Nate
deal with reasoning,
problem solving,
and attention deficiencies.
That's why athletes concerned
about their concussions
are now seeking out
Dr. Stringer.
Stringer's research is showing
some remarkable outcomes
in brains of patients
diagnosed with MCI,
Mild Cognitive Impairment,
an early form of dementia.
Working with researchers now
at the University of Michigan
and Penn State
University,
they compared people with MCI
to people with healthy brains.
The orange indicates
activity in the brain
while they perform task.
In the MCI brains,
far fewer areas
are lighting up
before cognitive
rehabilitation.
These brains are from
patients who actually
have gone through
cognitive rehabilitation.
And you can see,
they look a lot more like
the healthy controls.
A lot more activation in
the frontal part of the brain,
which is the part of the brain
that really becomes engaged
when we're using a
strategy to compensate
for memory
difficulties.
(Jaye)
Essentially, other
parts of the brain
can pick up the slack
for parts that no longer
function as they should.
What researchers know
about the long-term impact
of concussions on a brain
is constantly evolving.
The research is
too new to show
if rehab could delay
onset of brain disease.
And, you know, my heart--
anyone's heart, I think,
just has to go out
to the athletes.
Because, you know, they put
everything on the line.
And I think,
oftentimes,
they don't even realize what
they're putting on the line
by just playing the
sport that they love.
(Jaye)
While Lewis comes to grips
with what he can
and can no longer do,
he is also coming out.
Until now, he has told
no one of his struggles,
including his own family,
in Moultrie.
The secret they shouldered
alone for 15 years
will now be shared.
(Sherry)
His family not knowing,
and us doing this,
has just opened up
another door.
It feels good.
And it feels scary.
(Jaye)
Lewis hopes he has
found a new way forward
off the field.
One that can lead him to
a life free of suffering.
Love you.
I know, I know,
love you too.
Nate is on a
maintenance program,
using cognitive strategies
on his own.
He sees Dr. Stringer
and his therapist
every four to six weeks
for booster sessions.
He's also learning to accept
that he will always grapple
with cognitive
challenges.
♪♪
Did you know that the
natural vibrations of cars
can make people sleepy?
Even if they're well
rested and healthy.
This is a big problem,
when you consider
how much time
we spend in our cars
these days.
Especially since
20% of fatal crashes
involve driver fatigue.
In a study out
of Australia,
volunteers were
tested in simulators
that mimicked driving
on the highway.
Well, after just
15 minutes of testing,
those volunteers showed
signs of drowsiness.
Drowsiness that peaked
at the 60 minute mark.
The research is ongoing.
But the hope is that
future carseat designs
could include
something to fight
this vibration-induced
sleepiness.
What's the difference
between enjoying something
and being addicted to it?
We know people can be
addicted to many things.
From food, to alcohol,
to drugs.
Now add video games
to the list.
The World Health Organization
has named Gaming Disorder
as a mental health
condition
in its International
Classification of Diseases.
We take a look at
Gaming Disorder.
What it means to video gamers
and their brains.
It looks like a Christmas
morning race down the stairs.
But instead of presents
beneath the tree
for the Watt Brothers,
there is this.
That race is because
whoever gets there first...
Rock, paper,
scissors, shoot.
... plays first.
Rock, paper,
scissors, shoot.
It's sort of dystopian,
like "The Hunger Games",
where it's a
battle royale.
And then it comes down
to one person who wins.
(Jaye)
"Fortnite" is a far cry from
your father's video games.
I get irritated a lot.
You can't stop.
You can't pause the game.
I don't wanna say
it's addictive,
but it is addictive.
I started to feel like
it was unhealthy, um,
when they started
playing...
Bro, Evan.
... so often that...
Oh, he put a trap down.
... when I called them,
they got irritated.
Shoot the rocket.
When they couldn't
pull away from it,
is when I started to
realize it was unhealthy.
Or when their response
to me was disrespectful
as a result of me pulling
them away or interrupting.
(Jaye)
It's a slickly-produced,
intense game of survival.
And currently one of the
most popular in the country.
Dawn and Jwyanza Watt
do not allow their boys
any technology during
the school week,
which can turn weekends
into free-for-alls.
I think the amount of time
that is consumed is unhealthy.
(Jaye)
The World Health
Organization's definition
of Gaming Disorder
includes...
behavior that lasts
for 12 months,
gaming taking precedence
over other interests
and daily activities,
and playing the game despite
negative consequences,
whether it's trouble at work,
school, or at home.
What would your boys choose
to do over video games?
Sports.
Two of 'em, for sure,
would much rather do
sports over video games.
(Jaye)
Dawn, do you agree?
No.
(laughs)
Why do I keep on
getting hit?
You're on your own, man.
(Jaye)
This battle is playing out
in homes across the country.
A battle of balance.
How to allow gaming without
it becoming a problem.
It's important
we recognize
people are truly
struggling with this.
(Jaye)
Emory Brain Health
Psychiatrist,
Dr. Justine Welsh,
is an adolescent
addiction expert.
We actually see, um,
a common thread
between the release of
the chemical, dopamine,
which is largely
responsible
for the sensation of
pleasure and reward
in the same area
of the brain.
And to the same degree
or magnitude, um,
that playing a game has
for someone who may
be addicted to it,
versus using alcohol
and other drugs.
(Jaye)
So, gaming is as addictive
as other addictions?
It can be.
(Jaye)
As with other addictions,
Dr. Welsh says gamers
develop a tolerance.
Meaning they need
to play longer
to get the same
dopamine reward.
And we also sometimes see
a withdrawal syndrome,
where someone can become
anxious or irritable
when limits are set,
or the games are
actually taken away.
And some of those symptoms
really closely mimic
the symptoms that we see with
substance use disorders.
Yeah!
Oh, shoot, no.
People.
(Jaye)
I felt, in asking other parents
to share their struggle,
that in this case,
I should share mine.
The one lurking
in our basement.
Oh, shoot.
(Jaye)
My son, Jude, is 13.
Very 13.
We limit his
playing time.
Not a popular decision.
You don't think that
we should limit
your video game
playing time?
No, no, no, no.
You should
totally limit it.
Because, uh, I agree that
all boys would be on it
for hours and hours.
My port of fort now.
My friends, their parents
don't even care.
Like, one of my friends
are on six hours a day.
(Jaye)
I can't fact check
that last statement,
but I do think
it's interesting
when Jude explains how he feels
after playing for a long time.
I get, actually,
very bored and mad,
and my head gets angry,
and I get really frustrated.
(Jaye)
Is his frustration
because he's addicted?
Or because he's
a 13-year-old boy?
The World Health
Organization says...
(Dr. Welsh)
What are the screen habits?
How much time is the child
or adolescent spending?
And what are
they playing?
And what really happens
when you set limits?
(Jaye)
My son will argue our limits
are killing his social life.
He meets up with
his friends online.
So do the Watt Brothers,
and millions of adolescent and
adult gamers across the country
who have virtual
gaming friends.
Girls now account for
almost half of players.
(Dawn)
It does create kinda the
social environment for them.
Um, they connect
with kids
they probably wouldn't
connect with at school,
as an example.
There's strategy
around it.
There's, you know,
critical thinking,
and things like that,
that I like about it.
It's a very
new diagnosis.
We still have a lot
to learn about it.
(Jaye)
More research is underway.
And long-term impacts of
too much gaming are not known.
Treatment is Cognitive
Behavioral Therapy.
A talk therapy
that helps people
adopt healthier
behaviors and thoughts.
The battle for
balance will rage on
in homes across America,
with some parents still
clinging to the hope
that video games
do not reign supreme.
I think you'll have--
at least one of 'em
will say that
there's other things
they prefer to do,
than video games.
And I would call
that denial.
(laughter)
Some mental health experts
say addiction to gaming
can be a symptom of
an underlying condition,
like depression,
or ADHD.
And that just
because a kid
spends hours
playing video games
doesn't mean
they're an addict.
That's why Gaming Disorder
can only be diagnosed
by a mental health
professional.
Spinach or tortilla chips?
Peaches or salted-caramel
ice cream?
Well, research
is showing us
that the reward centers
of our brains
are craving
carbs and fat.
And that is something
that doesn't happen
in most natural foods,
but is pretty much
the definition
of a lot of
processed foods.
Think pizza, burgers,
french fries, doughnuts.
So, 200 adults
underwent brain scans
while they were shown
photos of various snacks.
And they tended to
choose the ones
that had both carbs
and fat in them.
So what does it mean?
Well, it is giving us
insight into why we overeat,
and how our craving
for carbs and fat
are making us
overweight.
Our final story is
about expectations.
How they're lowered
when receiving a
devastating diagnosis,
and how they're exceeded
when a passion is discovered.
One so strong that even
a rare genetic disorder
cannot stop it.
Joshua Clark
is his name,
and you won't
soon forget him.
(trumpet playing)
(Jaye)
A young man
playing a trumpet.
It could be a glimpse inside
a typical suburban home.
But nothing about
Joshua Clark is typical,
going back to before
he was even born.
I was laying there,
and the girl said,
"Oh, I see it's a boy.
"We see the little turtle."
And I was like, "What?"
She was like, "Yeah."
And then she went, "Mm."
It was very low.
Like, it wasn't dramatic.
It was like a "Mm.
Mm-hmm."
(Jaye)
Tuberous sclerosis.
Two words Cheryl Grant
had never heard.
Two words that would change
the course of her life,
and that of her son.
Tuberous sclerosis affects
the brain, the eyes,
the lungs, the heart,
the kidneys.
So it's a lot of
different organ systems
that could be affected.
(Jaye)
The rare genetic disorder
that affects 50,000 people
in the United States
causes benign tumors,
and masses called tubers,
to grow in the brain
and other vital organs.
Joshua's brain
has many tubers.
But also had a giant
cell astrocytoma tumor.
A type associated with
tuberous sclerosis.
So if this is the size of
a five-year-old brain.
The tumor was
half that size.
It was gigantic.
(Jaye)
The surgery to remove
part of that tumor
dramatically impacted the
left side of Joshua's body,
and his
cognitive function.
(Cheryl)
He's probably about along
the lines of a 15-year-old,
14, 15-year-old.
Uh, sometimes,
like, if someone
asks me a question,
even if it's a
yes-or-no question,
it'll still take me
a while to answer
because I have
a cognitive delay.
♪♪
(Jaye)
Joshua works at
the cafeteria
of a nearby
elementary school.
Using the stronger
half of his body
to compensate for the half
that struggles with basic task.
Biggest thing is,
you have to make sure
that this thing
doesn't become your God.
You will use it as an
excuse for everything,
if you let it.
How are you guys doing?
Doing pretty well.
Mm-hmm.
(Jaye)
Emory Neuro Oncologist,
Dr. Soma Sengupta,
manages Joshua's disorder.
Harsh chemotherapy and
invasive brain surgeries
have been replaced,
for the most part,
with drugs that now
target specific pathways,
keeping the tumors
in check.
Can you show me
the hand again?
Okay.
It's kinda-- like I said,
it's kinda tense right now.
(Dr. Sengupta)
Mm-hmm.
(Jaye)
Botox helps to
loosen his hand
in the left side
of Joshua's body.
But there are many
tubers in his brain
that cannot be removed.
(Dr. Weinberg)
You have a triangle where
it's just kinda bright,
and brighter
than it should be.
And when that's disrupted,
that's an area of-of injury,
or abnormal tissue there.
And you'll kind of see
other areas throughout,
where they're
scattered throughout.
I mean, it's hard to-to give,
like, an accurate estimate.
But I would say
it's more than 10.
You know, probably many
more than that, even.
Compared to a normal brain,
this is very abnormal.
I mean, there's large
regions of the brain
which are-are
completely different
than they would look
in a normal brain,
in someone
like you or I.
(Jaye)
There is an area
of Joshua's brain
that is interesting
to his doctors.
It's the part not ravaged by
surgery and genetic disorders.
(Dr. Weinberg)
Music and language
and auditory processing
are kind of in similar-in
similar parts of the brain.
And, uh, then a lot of
that is done through
the-the lower parts
of the frontal lobe.
So, like, down here,
in which his brain is
relatively normal in that area.
(trumpet playing)
(Cheryl)
The first time
I noticed was, um,
he was in his car seat
and he was humming.
And I was like, I didn't
know babies hummed.
You know?
(Jaye)
In a life filled
with valleys,
this 22-year-old
has found his peak.
(imitating trumpet playing)
(Jaye)
Joshua Clark is
a jazz artist.
With his mouth,
with his one hand,
with all of himself.
(playing keyboard)
What music does for me,
is it helps me forget
about my frustrations.
I feel kinda
like an outcast.
(Jaye)
So does music make you
not feel like an outcast?
It does.
(Jaye)
He wants to bring
jazz to Millennials.
You know how you're in traffic,
you're at a red light,
and there's that
one person...
(beatboxing)
"Yeah, yeah, yeah",
you know?
Things of that nature.
But, uh, I wanna put
that with jazz music,
to see what it
sounds like.
(Jaye)
His musical ability provides
an unlikely soundtrack
in a life filled with
love and struggle,
and an unknown future,
where life-shortening
complications often lurk.
(Cheryl)
This is like a surprise.
'Cause you don't know
what you're unwrapping.
(Jaye)
In between her two jobs,
Cheryl unpacks boxes
in their new home.
I love this
picture of you.
Look at that red clay dirt,
down home.
You were so happy.
I wouldn't
change anything.
It's made me
a better person.
Like, it's made me a more
sober-minded person.
It's made me
more strategic.
Like, I think more,
now, globally.
I see the value that
everybody brings to the table,
now that I have
this child.
Even my own self worth.
And I think it's
just made me...
just a better person.
He has the best outlook
of anybody I know,
and does not complain.
And he's-- you know,
I raised him,
but he's so much
better than I am.
And I'm so glad.
(laughing)
He's not near as
petty as I am.
(Jaye)
Tuberous sclerosis
stole a lot of dreams.
His mother says,
music brought them back.
Oh, I want him happy.
I-- you know, I just picture
him somewhere in France.
Playing music,
and meeting people,
and having a home
of his own.
(Jaye)
In a world that has
not always welcomed him
because of his
differences,
Joshua does not yearn
for a different path.
He wants to give back.
I hope that
whatever I attend--
intend to accomplish,
it'd be for not
only for my good,
but for the good of
people besides myself.
You know?
'Cause what-what
good would it do
if it's just benefiting
myself and nobody else?
I'm just glad
to be living.
It's the little things that
flourish into big things.
(imitating trumpet playing)
♪♪
Medical interventions
control his tumors,
but Joshua and his mother
also have a positive outlook.
And they have not
had an easy life.
But they're grateful,
even for the hard parts.
A lesson we'd all
do well to remember.
That does it for us
this week.
We'll see you next time,
on "Your Fantastic Mind".
♪♪